and joining us now with the reaction is
former press secretary for vice
president pence mark Lauder and former
Obama economic adviser Austan Goolsbee
or a good evening gentlemen mark I'll
start with you I mean the president
certainly has a lot to talk about 14
months 15 months in with all of the
numbers that he talked about with
unemployment and jobs and three million
new jobs since election day I mean
there's pretty much a very positive
message it's kind of interesting that
there would be any resistance toward his
effort at least to create the
infrastructure effort that apparently is
stalled in Congress why do you think
that is well it's basically what you
just said it's results versus resistance
and in this case the president has the
results but he's not satisfied yet he
doesn't want to just make America great
again he's now talking about making and
building an even better America again
and that's where his focus is he took
that message right into the heart of
blue-collar Ohio he's going to take it
around the country for the rest of the
the next three years and that's the
platform he's gonna move this country
forward with all right in Austin I mean
you would agree wouldn't you that our
roads and our bridges are certainly in
need of repair and yet the Democrats as
Mark indicated continue to resist this
is not a political issue why wouldn't
they come together to make sure that we
repair our roads and bridges and get a
better infrastructure well I I do agree
with you I thought you he ought to hire
you guys to clean up his speeches the
actual speech there was you you made it
a lot more coherent and on message he
was all over the place I mean he's
talking about Roseanne and talk about
North Korea on infrastructure it's not
just him they love him for that that's
what I eat he got elected you may be
right you may be right but on the issue
of infrastructure it's not just the
Democrats that are holding him up what's
going wrong is the president's
infrastructure plan is not actually a
plan for federal increase in spending on
infrastructure of the size he's talking
about he's trying in his plan to put the
cost on to the states and even the
Republican governors are saying they
don't want
to do that plan so that's the problem
he's got to find more of a common ground
mark well it infrastructure has always
been a federal state local partnership
and what the president's talking about
doing is taking two hundred billion
dollars and using that to leverage local
state private-sector monies to the tune
of 1.5 trillion and that's the way we
should be doing it because right now
there are too many states and local
governments especially in some of the
areas in the Northeast that they get
most of their money in from the federal
government and they just go ahead and
waste it if they put more skin in the
game then maybe they will be better
stewards of that money and make sure
that the projects are getting built on
time under budget and that's what the
president's focused on you know Austin
but I don't I don't agree with that that
was not a correct statement all across
the country historically we've had 90%
of the money paid by the federal
government and they require a 10% match
from the states in every state not just
New England and this plan of the
president is 200 billion that he's going
to cut 200 billion from infrastructure
in other places for a net increase of
nothing and shifted so that 80 plus
percent of the cost goes to the states
that's why the states are opposed to the
plan you are asking why is it stalled in
Congress it's because of that well you
know what but but Austin you also have
to admit I mean the way to react to
President Trump if you're a Democrat is
to resist but mark can you answer his
question well no he's absolutely right
it's always been a federal split but
what I'm saying is because so much of
that money comes from the federal
government it is often wasted when you
put more local state skin in the game
which is what the president is calling
on in addition to putting private-sector
money in you know it we better manage
because it's their money their limited
resources that they're gonna have to
better look out for and make sure
they're delivering projects that have
the greatest impact to their taxpayers
to to their economy and that's where the
president's focused on this and it's the
right focus
it's called accountability mark austin
thanks so much for being with us tonight